(classical music)
- [Narrator] You're in Mississippi
and everywhere you go, tamales.
Those magical little snacks of corn flour
and meat packed into a corn husk.
Tamales, tamales, tamales.
So if you've ever wondered
what Mississippi tastes like,
it tastes like me, the tamale.
My journey starts almost
a hundred years ago.
It's 1930 and Mexican migrants
are trickling into Mississippi.
They bring along a taste of home.
Their version of the
sandwich, me, the tamale.
- My great grandfather came here
from Mexico City, jumped the trains,
ended up in Mississippi.
He decided to make his family's homemade,
hand rolled hot tamales and in 1939
opened up this place and
started selling tamales.
You have to understand
this is a family thing.
I'm the fourth generation.
The same generation of people who
have been coming to the Big Apple Inn
for the last 78 years
are also generational.
When they eat a tamale,
they always have a story.
My daddy used to bring me here.
His daddy had the same kind of story,
his daddy had the same kind of story.
Tamales caught on here and it
became a staple in the city.
- [Narrator] So there I am
winning over the Mississippi natives
and as I make my way up into the Delta
my location may change
but little did I know
that the tradition of family
most certainly would not.
Just like Geno and his
grandfather at the Big Apple Inn,
I bring the Scott family together,
a family who has gone on to be known
as the first family of
tamales in Mississippi.
- In the early '50s, my father
bought the recipe from a Mexican guy.
My mother and father taught me,
my sisters and my niece,
all of us together,
we making hot tamale.
We just one big hot tamale family.
Any business that's family oriented,
I think it'll last longer.
- [Narrator] Much like the Scott family,
the Doe family is made up of a long line
of tamale makers.
Doe's Eat Place is a landmark restaurant
that helped propel me
to become the backbone
of Mississippi cuisine I've become today.
- My daddy started this restaurant in 1941
with my mother.
We've been here 76 years.
Mama had a sister that was living here
and daddy had a couple,
two or three sisters,
that were living here so they all came
and rolled tamales.
Yeah, a lot of people
ask us how did tamales
get prevalent in the Delta.
It's been family.
The family's been here all the time.
- [Narrator] As tamales made their way
from Mexican culture to
African American communities
and on to Mississippi's white population,
there's one thing that
remained a constant.
Family, the most southern concept of all.